Thanks thanks for coming so I'm going to
talk about mostly linear maps and
attacks today and what I'm going to talk
about is going to be based on three
works the first by myself gentlelady
from Europe 13 then a another multimedia
map construction by could only point and
tabuchi and then a very recent Europe 15
paper which is an attacks paper by John
Hanley ruin sterling
I can put it in there okay so here's the
outline I'm going to start by talking
about what by linear map so I'm going to
as I describe what by linear maps are a
little intuitively also sort of hint
upon what multilinear maps are I'll
mention what the known results are some
of the applications they're going to be
to talks after this one an obfuscation
and other applications of obfuscation
both are going to talk about
applications of multi linear maps so I
won't spend too much time on it next
I'll move on to defining what multi
linear maps are I'll start with the
classical notion of multilinear maps as
has been envisioned in the literature it
sort of will build upon this intuitive
notion of multilinear maps that we will
have in our minds then what we are able
to realize is not this this traditional
notion of multi linear maps but an
approximate version of it so I'll start
with this classical notion and slowly
transform it into something which is the
approximate version and that is what
we're going to realize and then in I'll
give the two multi linear candidate
constructions the DGH scheme and the CLT
scheme and for each of them I'll give
you a sample of one of the attacks I
won't mention all of the won't go into
details of all the attacks but I'll
mention what all exist at the end of the
talk to give you a glimpse on what's
happening and what is the status of each
construction okay so let me start with
bilinear maps and we'll intuitively by
the end of this part we'll also have an
idea about what multi linear maps are
and we'll have an idea of why they are
important and what is roughly known so
by linear maps are this extremely useful
tool in cryptography they have just a
lot in a lot of applications starting
with the first works by doing morning
frankly so do gave the first three party
non-interactive tht protocol using by
linear maps and born in Franklin gave
the first identity based encryption
scheme and as the name suggests
cryptography by linear maps work over
these cryptography groups which
additionally have a structure called the
called the bilinear map which allows for
pairing two things together okay so
formerly we have two groups G 1 and G 2
let's say both of prime order P with
generators G 1 and G 2 respectively such
that they come equal to this by linear
map II that takes us input to group
elements one from G both from G 1 and
outputs an element in G 2 okay so and
this map has this additional property
that for every a comma B in Z P if you
are to pair G 1 to da with G 1 to the B
then you get G 2 to the a B okay so
typically by linear maps are defined by
having a source group and a target group
i define it by having G 1 and G 2
because it's sort of more natural to
extend it in the setting of multi linear
maps also if you were to put in a and B
in this expression you essentially get G
2 as a pairing of eg 1 comma G 1 so in
in the setting where you have groups
with this additional structure the the
by linear map the decisional
diffie-hellman prompt problem turns out
to be easy so what is the decision of
the field problem or the DDA's problem
the problem says that if I was to give
you in a group G 1 to D a where a is
chosen uniformly at random and similarly
G 1 to the B where again be chosen
uniformly at random and a challenge
element T where T is either G 1 to be a
B or G 1 to D R where R is chosen
uniformly at random then an attacker
cannot tell which of the two values is
provided okay but once you have access
to so this problem is known to be hard
in in just primordial groups but if you
were to if you were to have these by
these special cryptography groups where
such a map exists then this problem
turns out to be easy so in particular if
you were to pair G 1 to D ever G 1 to
the B if he was indeed Z 1 to D a B then
these two pairings will evaluate to the
same value so this is going to be a G 1
comma G 1 to the power a B and same as
the spot so the devious problem is easy
well we're in crypto we're always in the
business of making hard problem assuming
hard problems why am I talking about
something which is easy so even though
this problem is is easy
the computational way variant of this
problem which is the CDH problem which
is that if I was to give g1 to the end
even to the B it's still hard to get or
compute G 1 2 G a B so a polynomial time
attacker will not be able to compute
this value okay it is this this
disparity between the easiness of the
decisional problem and the computational
problem that makes a lot of these
applications work up the specific
cryptography groups over which these
these pairings exist are the are the
elliptic curve groups with wheeler Tait
pairings or them additional cryptography
assumptions can be made over
subscription these additional
assumptions enable even more
applications so one specific assumption
that we would be very interested in is
that is a natural generalization of the
the DBH assumption specifically the
bilinear diffie-hellman assumption what
this assumption says that if I was given
elements G 1 G 1 to the AG will to the
be in G 1 to the C when ABC are chosen
uniformly at random then it's hard to
distinguish G 2 to the ABC from random
okay so in the setting of by lineae maps
putting two things in the exponent or
getting them to multiply in the exponent
sort of comes easy because because the
map should come equipped with this
additionally with this pairing operation
but if you were to put three things in
the exponent it's not only becomes hard
in fact even to just distinguish this
value from random okay and multilinear
maps are sort of a very natural
extension of this where in a care linear
map you get to put gate things in the
exponent or get get to multiply key
things in the exponent for free but the
moment i have k plus thing k plus 1
values in the exponent distinguishing
that value from random remains hard so
this notion of or this generalization of
bilinear map still setting multi maps
was first suggested by bonnie and silver
break and and sort of they also showed
various applications that would happen
if we had access to such a map but sort
of showed challenges that lie in in
constructing such maps using techniques
that were known for for the bilinear
setting so for they can for
multilinear maps what we do know now is
is their tip construction of multi
linear maps they're all approximate
whereas this approximate mean will
become clear as I define the notion the
and and the the first to sort of closer
to the envisioned world and the third
one is it's a it's even though it's
teach yet it's a gently gorbunov Halevy
so the red one is me the black one is
not me
so a the this construction achieves
multi linear maps which are which are
still sufficient for many applications
such as office keishon but are not
sufficient for all applications and
there are sequence of attacks we had
some attacks in the original ggh work
and there been many new attacks that
have come in the in the past few months
I would say these attacks work in
various settings and for when we talk
about multi linear maps it's not just
one assumption there are plenty in fact
extremely large class of presumptions
that you could potentially make on a map
and these attacks work for certain
specific settings some attacks work for
Magento settings some attacks work for
more limited settings and sort of a very
one has to think very carefully about
what applications one is looking at in
particular one point I want to stress is
that no none of these attacks are known
to or yet known to work on any of the
office keishon or most of the
obfuscation schemes that we know
furthermore you know well office keishon
is cool but multi-team apps seem to have
a lot of other applications as well and
you would like to instantiate the maps
in a way and recover those original
applications the new candidate scheme by
Qur'an at all which sort of builds upon
the the previous CLT maps from Kepler
2013 so provides a fix or a scheme that
is resilient to all or at least the
known attacks that we so far have and it
remains a very active area of research
sort of the bottom line in my eyes is
that very little in this area is known
we'll just start to describe the surface
and both constructions as well as
attacks are very much benefiting from
from the research in this direction okay
so as I said I'll mention very briefly
about two applications and there will be
a lot of talk on it so just very briefly
the first application were to talk about
is for the setting of non interactive
key agreement which is by which was
first proposed by dision Hellman for the
two party settings so the problem is as
follows with two parties Alice and Bob
they want to send one message to each
other so Alice gets to send a message
pka Bob Sansui gets to send PKB to Alice
and they are not dependent on each other
so they must send it simultaneously and
at the end of the protocol or just a
simple one round exchange they want to
establish a shared key kab said such
that only Alice and Bob have access to
the security and they want the security
guarantee that an attacker who gets to
see this communication in particular the
keys
piqué and piqué b should not be able to
figure out anything about this key that
they were able to establish the kab Jew
was able to extend it to the three party
setting using bi linear maps and Bourne
and silver were sort of very naturally
noticed that if one had access to
multilinear maps one could very readily
extend this result to the multi party
setting so let me very briefly describe
what the protocol is in sort of in the
two party setting in naturally extends
to the three party setting and and so on
so for the we'll start by the two party
setting in which the DDS problem is hard
so with Alice what she does is she
sample the random uniformly random value
a generates even to the a and sends it
to Bob M similarly Bob samples B
generates even to the B and sends us to
Alice at this point both of them can
compute the shared key G 1 to the a B so
Alice has access to the secret
information a she can exponentiate what
Bob just sends even to the B with a and
gets you into the a B and similarly Bob
having access to be could exponentiate
even to the a and get the same value and
by the decisional diffie-hellman problem
this value
indistinguishable from random so an
attacker cannot figure out what this
values this extends very naturally to
the three party setting once you have
access to by linear maps and the
protocol is again a very natural
generalization now that we have three
parties Alice Bob and Carol they
generate a BCE uniformly at random and
broadcast even to the edge even to the B
and G will to the C respectively and
each of them can compute the easy one to
match even to the power ABC so for
example Alice could could generate this
value by pairing together G 1 to the B
and G 1 at C and then exponentiating the
output with a the secret information
that she holds this naturally since
through the three party setting and in
and that and I'm not going to talk more
about it okay okay so the next
application which I'm just going to
mention just have this one slide on it's
off their office keishon they're going
to be the next two talks are going to be
on it the goal of software office
keishon is to make computer programs
unintelligible while preserving their
functionality
so let's say Alice has some program
piece in our favorite programming
language she wants to give this program
to Bob but only in an office catered
form so Alice wants Bob to be able to
execute this program on his computer
just as he could have executed the
original program P but she doesn't want
Bob to learn how this program P works or
what secrets are embedded inside it it's
sort of very tricky to define what I'm
what kind of secrets you're trying to
hide inside software whether we can hide
them how are we going to hide them and
what constructions are we going to build
to hide them and I'm not going to talk
about any of that and leave that for the
the next talk but I'm going to talk
about well not even the rest of the
application this is an outdated list
from two years ago or one year ago in
the but so the punchline is pick your
favorite primitive in cryptography it
could potentially be improved for now
not not necessarily in terms of
practical efficiency at least
theoretical efficiency sometimes but in
terms of men adding new features and so
on and it makes many many many new
applications which
previously thought of as as impossible
very much possible and that's why a sort
of the the stakes for for having secured
realizations for multimedia maps are
enhancing our confidence about what
exists are much higher okay so hopefully
this gives you some idea about you know
what by linear maps are what it
intuitively means to extend them to melt
in your maps why we should care about
them and sort of roughly what sort of
fear is going on in the world today so
let me now move on to definitions or
multilinear maps and I said I'll start
with the classical notion and sort of
slowly change it into what I call the
approximate notion and as I make these
changes of become clear what are this
sort of approximations we're making and
what is the weakening in sort of the
envision maps that we have okay so let
me start with the the classical notion
so it's just a very natural extension of
the the bilinear map definition instead
of having just two groups B 1 and B
sorry G 1 and G 2 I'm gonna have groups
G 1 G 2 up to G n all of the same prime
order P with generators G 1 2 G in
respectably and now instead of requiring
just one map which we took as input two
elements in c1 and and spit it out and
aluminum G 2 I'm going to require the
existence of a family of maps so eik is
a map that takes as input an element in
the group G I and I'm gonna and an
element in Group G K and maps it to an
element in Group G I plus K and these
maps exist as long as I plus K is less
than equal to n okay and they have the
additional property that if you were to
pair this this is properties analogous
to the pairing property from the
bilinear well that if you took any and
being able to pair G I to the ever G K
to the B then you get G I plus K to the
power a B so you can think of it as a
layered structure you have there the
lowest level the group G 1 and G 2 and
so on up at ng n at the top you can take
two elements in any of the two groups at
any of the two layers pair them together
such that the levels at the levels at
which they are the levels get added and
you get the the product of the values
that be that were encoded in this
particular case a and B
in the exponent so in this setting we
hope that at least the discrete problem
law problem is in each of the GIS
dissolve so in particular if I was given
GI to the T value a discreet in just
discrete login in an arbitrary group as
defined if you have the generator G if
you have given G to da it should be hard
to find it we're going to similarly
require that least if I'm giving you GI
to the a it should be hard to find it
but hopefully if I'm giving you GI to
the a you should not even be able to
compute GI minus one to be so you
shouldn't be able to go down so the only
way is going upwards and this this
hierarchy of levels but there's no
coming down but to enable a lot of the
applications we're going to hope that
generalizations of the bilinear
difficult assumption that I just
mentioned also be ok I'll talk about
what the assumption is later ok so let
me start with the sort of the
approximate version that I'm going to
get and this is what I'm gonna describe
I'm going to first start by giving a our
visualization of traditional by linear
maps so what I'm going to I am I talking
about by VA maps with our visualization
is because I'm going to make some subtle
points about by linear maps very clear
which are not going to be easy to
achieve in our setting and and and I
want to make those explicit so that we
can talk about how they are actually
achieved in our setting I'm going to
extend this traditional notion of by
linear maps into our approximate notion
of by linear maps and at each step it's
going to be sort of almost trivial to
imagine how that approximation is going
to get extended to the multi linear
setting and also to keep mentioning that
you can let do that yes so there is a
bone in silverwork said that you cannot
get something from the abelian varieties
so that's what they abelian varieties so
it's a kind of elliptic curve groups or
things similar to that that you couldn't
use those to build
varieties in order to use yes yes yes
yes yes yeah I think so they give a
impossibility I think I'm not completely
familiar with the techniques from that
paper but based on my recollection
they'd say roughly that it's not
possible yeah I think okay so now that
I'm remembering it said it's implausible
in some sense but not like to make an
assumption you first have to have a
candidate right we don't have a
candidate and they're saying that it's
unlikely to have a candidate so let me
talk about by EMF so inviting your Maps
we had the plain text space which is Z P
and consists of this elements 1 2 P and
each of these elements or these plain
text elements can be encoded I'm going
to call this as an encoding of each
plaintext element being encoded in the
group g1 so in particular if you took
one it can be encoded as G 1 to the 1 2
is encoded as G 1 to the 2 and so on
okay so do you recall the G 1 was the
generator of the group G 1 and similarly
for the group G 2 I could encode these
plaintext values as G 2 to the 1 G 2 to
the 2 and so on so one thing that sort
of very we take for granted in the
setting of by linear maps or sort of any
even any any even in primordial groups
is that it's it's it's it's it's it's
trivial to sample uniformly from ZP so
in our setting I'm mentioning it
explicitly because in our setting it's
not going to be very clear how what the
sampling means and how it's being done
the next is equality check so in in the
setting of by linear maps or the
invasion to a world the construction
from elliptic curves each element for
each plaintext value and as well as an
according of that plaintext value in
both G 1 and G 2
is represented by a unique
representation so if I have the encoding
Z 1 to the 1 if I was to represent it in
in in some way on a piece of paper then
there's a unique bit string that
identifies this encoding this is also
not going to be the case in our setting
so which is going to make a quality
check hard next is addition if you
wanted to add two encoded terms in G 1
you multiply the encoded values and that
big gives you an encoding of the sum of
the encoded values similarly if you were
to pair two in codings say in G 1 then
you get an encoding in the in it prepare
to encoding since G 1 and you get an
encoding in in G 2 which encodes the
product of the encoded values and
similarly for multi linear maps you just
have to have more groups and all these
operations hold in the same way as long
as you remain below the ceiling or the
wall in this case so the first
approximation that I'm going to make in
the setting of approximate by linear
maps and they're generalization to multi
maps is that I'm no longer going to have
each plaintext value and each encoding
be represented by a unique
representation but instead I'm going to
have a set of representation so one is
just one value but it is can be
represented by a entire set of
representation so each this you can
think of this set as a set of strings
and each string which I'm calling a
representation denotes the same value
okay and similarly for each of the
encoding so this encoding G 1 to the 1
is going to be represented by a set of
strings and I'm going to call each
element in the set a representation of
this encoding and so on and for multi
linear maps one thing to note is that
the the subscript pair denotes the level
of the encoding the plaintext and
elements I'm also going to call them
level 0 and codings and if I add groups
D 1 and G 2 the subscript here denotes
level 1 encoding and level 2 encoding
and the thing the superscript denotes
the plaintext value that's being encoded
the union of all these sets
together which is the union of s 0 1 and
so on is the set of all level 0 in
codings and so on so this is the set of
all level 1 encoding set of all level 2
in codings and so on so what I've
defined so far is I have a finite ring R
and sets s I says that for every I in n
that is the level level I in codings si
is the set of level ioud codings and
each set si can be partitioned into SIF
for each a in R so these are all level 0
encoding that can be partitioned into
these sets which are the representation
of the corresponding plaintext elements
so what they said was if you had a
completely the kind of structures we had
available there they were sort of I
don't know exactly but roughly we're
incapable of extending them in in some
ways and this is something that we build
on top of lattices and this is what we
are able to achieve in yes ring of the
plaintext element so right in the I was
talking about the groups but the
plaintext elements are in ZP which was
right so for now you can assume that's
the case so we're going to keep on
approximating them and then it's going
to become slightly different but let's
assume that ok so each si can be
partitioned into si a for each a where
si is the level I encoding the thing the
the next property which I said was
trivial for for the Z P was to say that
you could sample and uniformly from ZP
so now it's not very clear what I'm
going to if I want to sample a random
plaintext element what does it actually
mean because for each plaintext element
I have a represent a set of
representations and what are the proper
required is I'm going to require the
existence of an efficient procedure that
samples from the set s zero so if you
sample from F 0 you get going to get an
a value of 4 I'm going to require that
the this when you sample alpha it's
going to come from one of these sets
since they define a partition on this we
only require that the induced
distribution on a so if alpha comes from
a zero a that the induced distribution
on a be uniform so note that I'm not
requiring that I sample uniformly net
zero I'm not required if I sample from s
0 it's going to come from one of the
sets I am NOT requiring that be uniform
from the set it comes from but just that
the set it comes from I'm requiring a
uniformity over that ok so I'm going to
require the existence of a yeah so in
the construction we will not have the
ability to do that and for application
that seems that which it's for a lot of
the applications it's not necessary so
sampling output alpha such that alpha is
an se way for a uniform e ok so the next
is equality check in the setting of by
linear maps it was trivial in the
setting of this approximate by VM F what
I'm going to require is that if I was to
give you two representations from any of
the sets then you should be able to
efficiently tell me that they come from
the same set so equality test says that
if I give you two in codings
alpha and beta both at level I then this
procedure outputs 1 if and only if there
exists a such that alpha beta come from
the same si
yes also business that you can sample
from more than level zero or this is the
something is only for love sampling as
defined here just for level view right
so addition just like in the the
bilinear setting you could multiply it
to in coatings and that gave you an
encoding of the some of the encoded
values we would require the existence of
some traditional canonical canonical
addition operator that allows you to
take any two representations and add
them to obtain a representation in the
set of representation that corresponds
to the some of the original encoded
values so for example if you were to
take a representation from s1 1 and n a
presentation from s1 2 then and if you
were to add them using that that
operator then you will get s 1 3 and a
representation from s 1 3 yes yes I in
fact I haven't even placed any security
requirement you could just think of them
in the clear yeah yeah yes yes yes yes
yes
well I mean the quality did exist in the
bilinear setting as well Oh in that
sense yes yes yes yes yeah ok so just as
hygge said we could have since we have
addition we could also have subtraction
and in an August way and we could add at
any level if you had multi linear and
similarly I could also define
multiplication so in the in the pairing
world we had the well in the bilinear
pairing world we had this pairing
operation that you could get to G to now
I need to have a way of multiplying
representations to go to the next level
and be able to yes
so I haven't placed any security
requirements so far right so if you were
to just have unique representations the
things that I've said so far
it already satisfies that right if you
have a set yes so so far I haven't
placed any requirement the requirement
on any kind of uniformity that we put we
are ever going to place is going to come
from security properties we're going to
require that security holes and whatever
that you know to achieve that security
whatever best we can do to achieve
whatever uniformity is needed we're
going to do that but yeah okay so
multiplication can be naturally defined
where you have a by one thing it wants a
who goes question there is a difference
is that you do keep track of what level
you are at so you want to be when you
multiply things you if it's different
from from a more multiplicate
homomorphic multiplication in the sense
that you want to keep track of what
level you are in you don't want to go
beyond the inner play so the final
approximation which you're going to make
and which is sort of the trickiest one
and that's why I have it at the end is
that within these sets I'm going to have
a sub set of representations denoted by
this black spot and everything that I
just described so far addition
multiplication equality check they are
all required to work only as long as you
remain within this black spot so the
moment you step outside this black
region within each of the sets all bets
are off there's no guarantee about
correctness nothing is required anymore
and this is a to give you an intuition
similar to the fully homomorphic
encryption requirement where you can
keep doing computation but the moment
the noise becomes too large
no more computation can be done in the
sort of the result is completely
meaningless yes yes you know I
I didn't give in some encoding do I know
it is fun so how that is done is by
including the level of the encoding
along with the encoding so you whenever
you have an encoding you additionally
include with it what level it is what
noise it is and any time it's going to
be this information is passed on and
you're assuming that that's being done
sort of semi honestly if there is a
malicious setting then it's sort of
tricky and you have to take care of a
tipper okay okay so as I said in this
setting we're going to hope at least the
discrete log problem is hard so given an
encoding of a at level J it should be
hard to compute the encoding of a at
level J minus 1 and additionally we're
going to require sort of a plethora of
other assumptions the specific one that
I'm going to talk about mostly in the
start is the N multilinear
diffie-hellman assumption which says if
I give you level 1 in coatings of 1 a 1
up to a n plus 1 and a level encoding T
which is either an encoding of the
product of a 1 to n plus 1 or just a
random value then an efficient attacker
cannot tell those two part then I'm not
oh that's wrong so for the scheme to be
meaningful you're going to require that
otherwise if you sample outside the
black set then you can't do anything
more with it right we're going to
require that I'm going to can give a
construction which achieves that I could
have I just did it because it's simpler
to do it I can just talk about all the
things the properties I want and then I
can say that there's a black set inside
it
you you may go out yeah two together but
it seems to me that you have some notion
of the blowup of a computation and yeah
yes so support each it's a noise bound
on the elements so for each set I would
just say take some they are being
represented by polynomials or something
or integers I'm going to say that the
number is small then it is in the black
set if it is larger than this value it's
not in the black so if you're a ring
I'll define some norm over it and then I
would say as per that nom as long as
you're less than that bound I'm good so
as I said what I'm going to require is
that every time I give an encoding I
also specify the noise bound with it you
and the noise bound is exactly the value
that's in there and so on sequence of
these blacks that's growing black sense
right because once you add two guys in
the black city yeah yes so so that's why
I said there are these black sets what
I'm going to give you is something
that's going to be very very tiny in the
beginning and are going to become bigger
but their definition still holds for the
whole set right if you were just allowed
to do one computation and go hear the
noise growth will the moment the
definition just requires that if the
noise grows beyond this then your it
becomes useless it's not really it
doesn't seem like you can guarantee the
existence of such that if you keep
adding within these oh I didn't I didn't
say that I didn't said I just said that
one if you are in the set I can just
give the guarantee that you will land in
the correct oh yeah okay so you might go
outside
but yes sir yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes okay so now that was some
idea about the definition let me move on
to the two construction that I'm
interested in talking about the G jet
construction and the CLT construction
I'll start with the the G th
construction so so the the construction
is sort of roughly follows the n true
based fhe scheme are definitely with
this equality test parameter so if you
were to think about any fully
homomorphic encryption scheme it allows
you to do some computation additionally
that you need something that you need to
keep track office
how many multiplications that have been
done so forth so that represents the
level of multiplications that have
happened so far nd at the end you want
the capability to do an equality check
will also see that it suffices to do any
quality check at the end if you want to
do any quality check at the at one of
the earlier levels you can always bring
it to the top level and do the quality
check
but sort of become clear so let me start
with some background I'm going to work
over the ring R of the polynomial ring Z
X by FX where FX is is you can have
various choices but sort of the most
natural choice is X to the n plus 1
where N is a power of 2 a property of
this polynomial to keep in mind is that
the X to the n plus 1 is irreducible
over Z another one is that if you were
to take to any two elements in this ring
and you were to multiply them and take
the take the L 2 norm let's say if you
were to take a polynomial here and see
the the the vector representation of the
coefficients and you can define the L 2
norm based on that then if you were to
take the two elements multiply them in
the ring and take the norm of the two
this does not grow very fast this grows
only by a polynomial a polynomial n
factor compared to the the norms of the
the initial elements that you started
with
so I have this ring are and I'm also
going to define during the RQ which is
our by QR okay so in addition to being a
ring of polynomials over a mod F xn to
xn plus 1
I'm additionally going to have the
requirement the coefficients come from
zq instead from the integer space and
now I'm gonna tell you directly how the
scheme works and how what the public
parameters for the scheme are but first
I want to set the stage for what the
actual encodings are going to look like
and I'm going to start by describing
what they look like and then we will see
how they are going to actually be
generated in the scheme okay so there
will be a procedural there will be some
public parameters you'll use them to
actually generate the in coatings that
are needed in the scheme but first I'm
going to just say how they look like and
the public parameters are the same are
going to sort of hide two crucial secret
elements one is going to be a small
element G in RN so note that since G is
small the representation a and Q is
either way it's very large think of it
as the largest quantity in the system
since G's is I'm sampling this G to be
small the representation in in R and R Q
is going to be the same and when I say
small it is polynomial in n I'm also
going to sample a random invertible
large Zener Q and this is the public
parameters are also going to hide this
coefficients are small okay so in
particular the if you were to look at
the the vector formed by the
coefficients than the norm of that is
small
so - that's for the lattice attacks - in
order to prevent that you need the queue
to be exponential in n the exact
parameters I think there is some just
very recent result I just looked at it
it needs to grow I think maybe n square
or n cube or something like that but
some any other question G be small so
the smallness requirement on G is
required for functionality itself a Z
being you know the Z is sort of going to
be a masking factor and the best bet is
to choose it completely at random and to
the best of my knowledge it said if you
were to look at the attacks choosing a
small Z could perhaps also be okay we
don't know if an attack or in that
setting but being as conservative as we
can we just pick their larger see so
we've been testing to see if small Z's
are somehow vulnerable to attacks a I
let I be the ideal generated by G sub I
and I also has a lattice structure so
there going to be some additional
requirements of on gene I'm gonna
require the first is well it's small I'm
also going to require that being
portable in R cube I'm going to require
that our the the norm be a large prime
and furthermore this is sort of a
technical condition which where I
require that G inverse is a small in K
okay so where K is the same ring but
instead now you have a instead of the
coefficients coming from from from Z
they're coming there they're over
rational numbers
Gee's invertible right Derby right so
Dean North is in in cake but the first
invertible are in our queue yes that
means that ideal generated by G's the
whole ring right in our R it's not and
so with high probability a random
element is is invertible a large enough
random okay so in my scheme thus the the
the the the quotient group is going to
correspond to the scalars of the plain
text space so for ZP is going to
correspond to because the the corsets
are fine okay so so far in the
construction I have the strings are in
RQ and I've defined a small G that
defines a principal ideal I over R and
the because it's 1 plus I 2 plus I and
so on are going to do so each element in
this corset describes a representation
of an element in this set so for the
plain text element one it can be
represented by any element in this co
set yeah G is an art but it's it's both
as I mentioned same in our in our queue
because G's smoke so I'll use
interchangeably it being in in our in
our queue it's sampled because it's the
same unique representation and it
presents to like you can imagine as two
elements one in our in our queue but
they're represented by the same string
it's easy to define additional
multiplication operations over these so
in particular if you were to take any
two elements from any of the Co sets and
if you were to add them up then you get
an element in the addition corset and so
on recall that I also define this large
Z which I also required to be notable in
our queue in order to encode for example
to what I'm going to do is I'm going to
sample a small element in this corset 2
plus I again by small I mean a
polynomial within
this corset with small coefficients yes
G is going to be hidden zeal also going
to be hidden that's already enough to
say that you can distinguish between if
you're giving into yeah well if you
didn't have to it's it just looks like a
random element well for the smaller end
coding sort of becomes things become for
example zero is always going to be in
the coset right in the ideal itself zero
the trivial zero is there so for that
you can tell but in general you will not
be able to if you don't know Jesus it's
hard to tell if you give enough encoding
of zero long but no but if you give
enough encoding to zero right that's
giving the idea giving elements from the
level D recording is like giving G like
small elements there sorry it's like I'm
trying to hide that you can give up
random elements not of zero giving so
giving zero is like giving G right and
so the encoding proceeds by I take a
small element in the score set I divided
by Z and this operation is done in our
key in sort of this as I said is going
to be this masking factor which is sort
of hiding
what's encoded if you want to do the
encoding that higher level just keep
dividing by Z so if you had just divided
by Z again in our queue and you get a
level two encoding and if you want to
encode at higher levels you could keep
dividing and then you get
and if you wanted to add encoding the
suit took in an encoding say of course
@s play a small element C in s plus I
and a small element D in the course of t
plus I the encoding would look like C by
Z and D by Z and if you were to add them
in our queue what you're going to get is
an encoding C plus D by Z where the
operations are performed in our queue
with the guarantee that if C and D were
shot to begin with then C plus D is
still going to be short so the encoding
looks like and a small element from the
course at s plus T plus I divided by Z
so it looks like a legitimate encoding
of s plus T so you can't I as I said I'm
describing the things as they look like
I'm going to tell you how they're done
as we go further okay multiplication is
a procedural obviously if you multiply
two in coatings and 2 in coatings
consists of C by Z and D by C where C is
small and be small then if both of them
are small then the product is going to
remain is going to be smaller is going
to be from the product coset
so this encoding looks like an encoding
of s times T at the second level because
the the exponents of these Z's get that
added up right so this is how if you
were to multiply encoding that level I
and J you will get an encoding at level
I plus J okay so in general a level K
encoding of course at s plus 5 S Plus I
has the form C by ZK for a short C in S
plus I and if you wanted to add in
coatings all at the g8 level then you
just simply add them up and you get as
long as the the numerator in all of them
remains the sum of the numerators
remains much smaller than Q and if you
wanted to multiply the multi linearity
sort of proceeds by multiplying n
coatings and as you do that the the the
levels that the ink at which the
encoding czar get added up so in
particular the product encoding if the
original coatings were at level J I then
you get the the final encoding it level
solution of
okay so so far what I've described to
you something very simple or simple
which corresponds to the summer
homomorphic encoding speed where in
addition to some somewhat homomorphic
encryption you are additionally
remembering how much computation as has
happened so far
then roll well you lose a it sort of
becomes junk right because then there's
going to be a wrap around on the
numerator and then you have some element
but this element sort of is interpreted
in there in the d-link are not in in our
queue so lose the information about
which which place opposed so what I'm so
far not described is how sampling
inequality check works so let me to get
to that so sampling recall what I the
definition required that I be when I
sample from a zero the requirement is
that it will come from one of these sets
the set it should come from be uniform
in particular they induce if it comes
from a zero a then the induced
distribution on a should be uniform and
the idea to do that is actually very
simple just sample a small enough random
element in our queue and that already
suffices okay so when I say small enough
we have to choose the parameters
carefully in the sense that they have to
be larger than the coefficients of G but
much smaller than Q and how this follows
or follows in a way similar to the
smoothing parameter that that we know
talked about yesterday
recall that the the idea lie has a
lattice structure so if you were to look
at the fundamental parallelepiped of of
defined by the lattice corresponding to
I then it escalates the entire space and
if you were to sample from a Gaussian
distribution which is wide enough in
particular much larger or larger than
the smoothing parameter
and what you're going to get is you're
going to get an element that comes from
one of the corsets in the course that it
comes from it will be uniform okay so so
far I described what encoding is look
like and how you could sample a level
zero encoding yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yeah so so far I described how you
can have a a a hope you can sample a
level zero random encoding and so for
each you might have the s being large
but the corresponding representations in
the the ideal are small so s is just a
it's when you're looking at s it is s
plus some multiple of G so you you have
to find the right multiple such that the
whole thing is small so if you sample a
small element it is going to be one such
random s said with the additional
property that this thing is small okay
yes because the ideal itself is if you
is defined by G and itself is small
right we're sampling from a space which
is bigger than this idea yes
yes so I don't know so so for example
when you're adding something at let's
say one level one encoding in a 1 level
2 encoding right so you have one seemed
the denominator for one and Z squared
and the other the numerators get
multiplied as well so I mean I don't see
the nice structure I don't know if this
is a you know there's a Avenue for a tax
tear but I don't necessarily see a nice
structure right away Z's in the
numerators s alright when you do the
right it's not when you do the addition
at different levels right and I'm
assuming you're doing the operations in
R cube ok so now I'm going to tell you
how in Corden's are actually going to
look like so I'm going to publish in the
public parameters and encoding of 1 now
I'm going to do that I'm going to
generate a small in the course at 1 plus
I divided by Z in our queue and publish
the spell so this is the first value
that have so far along with the
parameters that are needed for the
scheme to work it's easy to sample as I
just described sample see from a wide
enough Gaussian and you get see that
course comes from a random cassette I
don't know which specific element when
text element encode within encodes a
random one of them now given this short
see what I can multiply it I can I can
multiply it with the level 1 encoding I
get an encoding
of this random coaster that I just pick
yeah if you want to go further you want
to upgrade to level I plus one you just
keep multiplying with wise so you can go
from a level I in cording to I plus when
according by multiplying it with y so
this is the first public parameter that
are published so far so next I'm going
to talk about the Equality test so note
that they're given this according a 1 it
suffices to do the Equality test just at
the final level because you can always
start at the lower level multiply it
with encoding the one needs to find a
little and you're sort of done right so
I'm going to just describe it quality
tested the the final level now in order
to do a quality test if I'm given to
encoding is U and u prime and I want to
check if they encode the same value it
suffices to check that the subtraction
of the to encode zero I can just pack
them in check if it's EU so I'm only
going to describe what means to check if
an encoding encodes you at the highest
level and in order to enable that we're
going to publish this this additional
parameter is the second one that I'm
mentioning so far which we call the zero
testing parameter which looks something
like x zk by g again the operations are
done in our Q and X here so Z and Z are
the same as before X here is going to be
somewhat short in particular the the
coefficients are going to be of the size
order routine in order to test if u is
an indeed an encoding of 0 i compute the
value W so if use an encoding of 0 then
C comes from the ideal and I'll multiply
u with the with the 0 testing parameter
I get Z by Z K times H ZK by G and what
I'm left with there CH by Z okay
and I output yes F if it's smaller than
Q part 3 by 4 let's say and no otherwise
so in particular I would say yes this is
an encoding of 0 if this value is small
and the no otherwise so correctness
while C is in the ideal or C is a
multiple of G so these
cancel out and what we are left with
something small so this is a this is not
exactly true because the problem is that
C prime itself may not be small so she
is a multiple of G but C prime itself
may not be small but it can be argued
let me do that so the solution is that
since I had a technical condition to
begin with I was requiring that the gene
versus is small itself so note that the
computation C times C times G inverse
which is exactly this computation here
on our Q when C prime C is C prime G
times G inverse in K is the same value
as an R because we know that this value
is an you know so since we have that C
small and gene was too small therefore
this whole product should also be small
if C is not in I then assume the case
that the W is less than Q by 2 so in
particular I'm saying it's it's less
than Q by 2 then we have that both WG so
you can take the G on the other side G
is small so both WG and CH are less than
Q by 2 okay so note that C is supposed
to be small by the definition of any
encoding since you was a valid encoding
C is required to be small it was sampled
to be smaller than or size square root Q
therefore the product CH is going to be
less than Q by 2 and G is small and W is
small based on the computation itself so
both of them are small and double since
both of them are small therefore we have
the W G is equal to CH in R so they're
equal in RQ but since they're both small
then they must also be the same in R but
this implies that by unique
factorization that either G divides C or
edge but actually shows and randomly
it's very unlikely to be in the idea so
we have that G divided see
take questions so I think this would be
a good point for me to take that top
yeah
but I'm happy to take questions I mean I
don't know if that depends on what so a
it so if G is a polynomial right with
small coefficients if you were to look
at you can look at the canonical
representations of these elements so
what that means is evaluating this
polynomial at the the roots of the
polynomial X to the n plus 1 which are
the primitive roots of the two in it to
annex primitive roots of unity so to
evaluate it you will get the the
canonical representation and the
transformation from this from from the
coefficient representation to the
canonical one is just a scaling and
rotation so it's also it's if you start
with a small element it's going to be a
small element up to a scaling factor
since those a since those the elements
in that canonical representation of
small if you take the inverses for them
so taking inverse in the canonical
representation is easy because the
values are just inverses so you can take
that and they go to be small with high
likelihood and then you can sort of yeah
is there a simple argument in one
dimension in one dimension is one over
that into higher dimension he doesn't
grow too much again yeah being size one
will be plenty small enough for what we
need things at random it's not going to
be a whole lot bigger than that
but we do have a factor of which closed
with the dimension that comes along but
yeah yeah the next construction I'm
going to talk about is over the integers
so there's no specific reason and
there's in fact the more like we should
find more candidates and more ways of
doing it right